while die hard fans probably know quite
a bit of sons of anarchy trivia
there are still untold truths about the
show that are definitely worth
discovering
for fans and anyone else interested here
are more facts that you may not know
about the show
in the show's first season charlie
hunnam's jax teller is introduced to
struggling with the pressures of being
the heir apparent of sam crow
aka the sons of anarchy motorcycle club
redwood original
it's something made all the worse for
the kid when he stumbles across some
writings by his late father
which confirmed jax's suspicions that
the club has become the opposite
of what was originally envisioned hey
you want me to be your number two
protect this club then i got no way
you're taking us
otherwise there's no trust in a 2008
interview showrunner kurt sutter
confirmed this comes directly from the
history of the hell's angels
but to really drill into the tensions of
such a club for seven pulpy seasons
sutter also focused on how motorcycle
clubs represent
certain american values while
aggressively rebelling against the
establishment
of course while they claim to be rebels
they're not exactly free
as sutter told the verge motorcycle
clubs say that they're all about ride
free and
the establishment but within the
structure of these outlaw clubs
there are more rules and regulations
than you or i have
by now the idea of the show being based
on hamlet has become an ingrained part
of sons of anarchy's mythology but it
isn't exactly correct
instead the play was used to inform
jax's character
and follow his journey into manhood
however sutter has also revealed that
hamlet served as a tonal reference point
for the show's dramatic arcs
with the place themes often overlapping
with those of sons of anarchy
though the showrunner has admitted he
cringes somewhat when the shakespearean
overtones are referenced by fans
they're also difficult to avoid in a
show where bodies litter virtually
every episode and where manipulation
deception
and hierarchy reigns supreme if charlie
hunnam's performance as the pretty boy
you don't want to mess with biker came
across as more authentic than anyone
expected
it's probably because the actor base
jacks on the 22 year old heir apparent
of an oakland-based motorcycle club
hunnam spent a lot of time researching
his role
and fessed up to the huffington post
that he got to know bikers and club
members
really well it's there that the actor
met the young biker who would inform the
complex and tragic character of jax
right down to the aesthetics including
the characters clean white kicks
and blue jeans hernam said the guy was
perfect for the character
as the actor explained his dad was in
the club and had been in the club his
whole life
and he was 22 he had 22 birthday parties
in the oakland clubhouse of this
motorcycle club
he was the heir apparent like the
history and future of that club
but it came at a cost the biker who
served as inspiration for jax was killed
the week after hunnam left oakland
right before the show started shooting
the actor still has a necklace from that
time which he wears as a memorial
with such a commitment to the role it's
no surprise hunnam got so deep in
character that he struggled to leave jax
on set
the british actor revealed to gq that he
put everything he had into the show
that includes dressing primarily in
plaid and oh yes
acting like a legit biker on and off the
screen with hunnam saying
i lived it as much as i could i never
got in a car the whole seven years
i was only on my bike and rolling around
with a bunch of real bikers
and occasionally acting like a maniac
the line between character and actor was
so blurred that hunnam even rode a
harley diner the same bike as jacks
it likely didn't help him to shake off
that sam crow scurs when he went home at
the end of the day
it also made saying goodbye to the
character intensely difficult for hunnam
who compared it to feeling quote like a
genuine bereavement
speaking to glamour about the emotional
process he admitted to returning to the
set
after the show had wrapped saying i'll
just walk around at night because i
wanted to be in that environment and go
through a personal process of saying
goodbye
one of sam crowe's most interesting and
beloved members is happy
the ironically named sergeant adam to
the motorcycle club who loves killing so
much that he tattoos a smiley face on
himself
for every life he snuffs out and the
actor behind the character
is about as legit as they come on the
show i'm bringing to the performance my
own personal life experience
on some level i've either seen it happen
or lived it
david labrada is a former member of the
hell's angels who was originally brought
on to be a technical advisor
however the guy is more than just a
biker when kurt sutter visited the
oakland chapter of which la bravo was a
member
he jumped at the opportunity to show off
his creative flair to the showrunner
speaking to collider la bravo said i
showed him that i wrote scripts and i
asked him to let me have a chance when
he cast the show
i got cast on the show and then he gave
me a real chance to write and here i am
as well as depicting the trigger happy
biker the brother
also wrote the 10th episode of the
fourth season hands
throughout the show's run sutter filled
the series with fun and usual cameos
usually featuring celebrities playing
against type season two notoriously
starred anti-fascist punk musician henry
rollins
as a violent neo-nazi season seven
featured the infinitely badass courtney
love as a sweet-natured pre-k
schoolteacher
meanwhile wholesome high school musical
star ashley tisdale
depicted a high class escort in season
5. sutter clearly had great fun with
these playful guest appearances
which were as surprising as they were
ugly fitting for the celebrity involved
where else could you possibly find david
hasselhoff playing a retired adult movie
star
or revered horror master stephen king
playing a cleaner of dead bodies
considering what a gargantuan presence
he brought to the show a slick samcrow
president clay morrow
it may seem utterly inconceivable that
sons of anarchy could ever exist
without ron pullman but unbelievable
that it might be
the original pilot actually starred
iconic character actor scott glenn in
the role
speaking to the av club about his brief
sons of anarchy experience
glenn actually sounded relieved that he
was fired from the show
the way that glenn tells it he found out
that effects was going ahead with the
series but without him in the role and
said
it was ultimately probably one of the
better things that could have happened
to me
enter pellman who gave npr his own side
of the story
revealing that although he's a fan of
glenn's work the actor divulged about
glenn's performance that quote the
network decided that they weren't
getting what they were hoping
this required pullman to take on the
role with hardly any prep time which
might explain why he never
exactly became accustomed with riding a
hog the way his fellow sons of anarchy
co-stars did
when i would start the bike and i would
get ready to pull out at the end of a
shot you know after all the dialogue was
over with people would go
cut cut cut eager but not often marked
half sack was a fan favorite for the two
seasons that the character managed to
survive on sons of anarchy
and he likely would have lasted even
longer had actor johnny lewis not as
sutter to cut his time short
with certain explaining johnny wasn't
happy on the show
creatively he really wanted out of his
contract
just a couple of years after leaving the
series a 22 year old was found dead in a
driveway in los angeles after allegedly
beating his 81 year old dan lady to
death
the actor was reportedly struggling with
severe mental health issues at the time
saturn published a blog post responding
to the actor's death
in which he admitted that he
unfortunately wasn't surprised by the
events
and called it a tragic end for an
extremely talented guy
who had unfortunately lost his way
suffice to say fans were utterly
devastated when jax's rider die bestie
opie was horrifically killed off at the
start of season five
and it seems that the cast and crew of
the show were hurting just as much as
fans
over the lovable character's demise to
help actor reinhurst and the rest of the
cast properly say goodbye to the
character
hunnam bought his friend and co-star a
samurai sword and encouraged him to use
it to remove his beard
as sunum tells it the actor hadn't
shaved for the three months since he
left the show
in fact he hadn't shaved once since
landing the role of opie
which had been over five years prior
venom explained
it was a catharsis that we all needed
for him to get rid of that beard and for
all of us to just let ob die
cue a supremely emotional video of the
symbolic beard cutting
in which hearst hunnam and mark boone jr
absolutely sob as they take turns
lopping off her beard
before watching the remainder be shaved
off his face see
they're big softies at heart really
let's face it
wearing a whole lot of leather is one of
the least appealing options no matter
the weather
so to have to wear such a challenging
costume during long work days on set in
100 degree heat
yeah it's less than ideal however that's
exactly the environment that the sons of
anarchy cast and crew found themselves
in
while filming the show as kim coats told
entertainment weekly during a set visit
we used to call it doing the timber we'd
lose a crew member a week from passing
out
boom gone tommy flanagan who plays chibs
on the show
was once in such bad shape from the heat
that he was even sent to hospital for an
iv
super fans of sons of anarchy had the
final episode of their favorite show
spoiled due to a stupid throwaway
mistake
the snafu was because of the release of
a sons of anarchy guidebook
that was immediately sent out to fans
who'd pre-ordered it the book arrived
just before the final episode
and it basically screamed sensitive plot
points in the faces of unprepared fans
kurt setzer was understandably livid
about the mistake
despite adding that there were many
different people he could blame for the
bug being delivered far too early he
also decided to shoulder the brunt of
the blame for coming up with the idea
for the book in the first place
sata apologized profusely and also urged
people not to ruin the ending for others
creator and showrunner kurt sutter built
a bit of a reputation as a blunt-talking
maverick
drawing his days working on sean ryan's
a shield
sutter's reaction to criticisms of the
show's third season which saw the club
head to ireland
could politely be described as vitriolic
he later called out specific critics who
reviewed each episode in another fiery
post on his own blog
after sutter's first post-sun show the
bastard executioner failed to find an
audience and was cancelled
he wound up returning to the world of
the sons with mayans mc
a spin-off he co-created with elgin
james set three years after the events
of sons
mayans mc deals with an offshoot of the
mayans who were depicted in sons of
anarchy as antagonists
and then allies of charlie hunnam's jack
stella the spin-off deals with jd
pardo's easy and his struggles
with the mayans having a different
structure and culture than the sun's
to make the voices authentic sutter was
committed to hiring people of color
telling the hollywood reporter i didn't
think that it made creative sense to be
the sole voice of a show that takes
place in an entirely different culture
that attitude probably led to sutter
being fired from his own co-creation
sutter says fox's parent company disney
disliked an off-color joke he wrote
about walt disney
an issue he believes he compounded by
writing more jokes
however the apparent reason for his
ouster stemmed from complaints about his
behavior
sutter moved on and will direct his
feature film debut bloomhouse's
this beast check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your
favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell
so you don't miss a single one